you wonder when you think about this
stuff like even with iran because iran
signed a 25 or 400 billion dollar deal
with
china right that's the deal that they
signed when they
uh said hey you want to do this trump
we're going to go take advantage this
and get with china and china is the
number one competitor to
uh us
do you think today's administration of
iran cares whether they have a good
relationship with u.s or not like do you
think they wake up in the morning saying
okay let's have a meeting guys let's
figure out a way how we can be better
with u.s do you think they give a
at all i would say it's probably the
opposite is that they're they're trying
to come up with ways to piss us off get
under our skin and degrade that
relationship with them i totally agree
okay so if that's the case
and they're saying well we're going back
to see
10 months of negotiation state
department says the diplomacy will cease
with coming weeks after they're going to
go back to tehran you think they care
like you think they're sitting there
saying hey boss we have to improve this
relationship with us or else we're going
to lose
yeah personal questions yeah go forward
being born in iran yeah and being a
proud iranian born in iran made in
america serving in the military being a
world-class entrepreneur
when you hear these types of stories or
just iran comes up how does that make
you feel just as a as a
citizen yeah all i think about is
progress all i think about is i got kids
that i'd like to show them
jet that i was raised on a street called
hojet i want to take him to bandar
pahlavi port of pallavi to show him
caspian sea i want to take him to gem
hospital where i was born i want to take
him to the kebab place we would go to
hooch i want to take him to the city
gandhi you know i want to take him i
want to go show him those places i can't
i want to take him to espahan which is
the only place we went on vacation with
my mom and dad when they were married to
each other i i listened to the song by
mauin who's a famous persian singer who
sings a song saying de la mix fahnbergam
my heart wants me to return back to
esperhan it's the only vacation i ever
went to it's a great song it's a very uh
heartfelt song i i i love that song so i
i think about progress for me to go i
want to go visit iran tomorrow i want to
go see what the place is at tomorrow
uh i remember going to the shaw's
castles and mansions and visiting it and
touring and seeing all these pictures
being
upside down that's what i think about so
for me every time i hear stories like
this
i think to myself we're going backwards
because remember the green part was it
the green party in iran that was trying
to do a coup do you remember the green
party uh can you pull up iran green
party it was something like that
the green movement or green party they
had something that was going on
iran uh a
green party of iran yeah they were they
were pushing back to
get iran to be free again you saw them
at the embassy you were seeing them
everywhere and they were making some
progress under trump there was a minute
where the people of iran could have
revolted to change things but every time
it happens a president changes
i think if trump would have stayed
president for eight years and he would
have just kept going if you remember gas
prices at one point were so expensive
people just stood they're not even
driving duck i can't afford to buy gas i
don't know
you don't remember this like a year and
a half ago it was so bad people just
are walking they're like i can't how am
i going to pay for this gasps the
sanctions were out of control it was
that time but the point is
as much as you're saying well the
sanctions were out of control if the
current regime in iran falls
somebody has to replace it and that
somebody that replaces is hoping to be a
different philosophy with relationships
with
neighboring countries like israel would
be better u.s would be better and it
would be back and forth but it's not
been like that since 1978. yeah i'm
going to go to iran tomorrow but i can't
go to iran tomorrow so if my motives are
a different motive then maybe the
average person's motive that's worried
about the fact that we kiss i'm selling
money and hey this guy's going to
retaliate and do another 911 to the us
i'm coming from a different story where
does because you're a christian
and i don't know what percentage of iran
are christians i i'm sure one percent is
less than jewish less than one percent
but they are the stronghold of hold of
shiites in the middle east and the rest
of the middle east is for the most part
sunni how does that weigh into their
relationships with the rest of the
middle east uh being a being the shiite
stronghold of the moon it's not going to
be pretty it's not going to be easy
because some people don't want the
revolution to happen some people want it
to stay the way it is
and the reality of it is in order for
revolution to happen
it's going to cost a lot of people's
lives it's not going to be pretty it's
going to be very ugly for that to be
taking place and you know as a parent
think about your mom your dad and you
got kids okay
and you're sitting there and you want a
revolution to happen you want iran to go
let's just say you're 70 years old you
remember when iran was amazing you're 50
years old you remember when iran was
great you wanted to go back to that but
at the same time to go back to that
you encourage your kids too much
to be radical and take a stand do you
really want to have some bad news of
somebody you know giving you a call
saying hey here's what happened to your
kid
your fear is what they're going to do to
your kids so you
almost discourage your kids of wanting
to revolt remember
this guy who got
erated
from isis was willing to take a
life of his wife and his kids
and himself to not give you the victory
that is so radical if you think about
that i mean to to be willing to do
something like that
i don't think the reasonable people on
the opposing side
are willing to risk their kids having to
go out there protesting and god forbid
somebody gets killed they're like listen
guys it's not worth it let's just let's
just be okay it's not a big deal so
they're not pushing back what would a
revolution even look like in iran
because correct me if i'm wrong i don't
think the people have access to guns
that sound like a
is with help you're not going to do it
without help
there has to be another country that's
helping
it's not going to happen just by the
people what providing ammunition guns
military support
yeah it's heavily heavy-duty involvement
it's not you the people won't be able to
do it are there uh do you have relatives
that are still there that you keep in
contact with uh i do yes from my
mother's side we have relatives there is
it uh difficult or like does that come
up at all where you talk about kind of
the pulse of what's going on there and
we we don't really talk about any of
that stuff i suppose they can't probably
right i mean it's being monitored no you
don't want to put them at risk if you
even if you even think about having
those types of conversations now but
here's what's interesting like today i'm
talking about this right i'm probably
going to get 50 messages on instagram or
twitter or
some social media platform of iranians
that are listening to our podcast
through a vpn underground system and
they're sending messages hey keep
talking about the stuff because we're
listening hey keep talking about the
stuff because we're listening but you
know in order for that to happen you
need an administration that
doesn't look at them and say hey you
know this is let's just negotiate with
them
it's very hard to negotiate with
reasonable people it's very unreasonable
very hard yeah when you're negotiating
with unreasonable people no progress is
going to take place these guys are not
reasonable people well this is where you
need to add them into mike's point this
is where you need israel to step up and
the the peace accords that have come
through the middle east that israel is
making because everybody's biggest fear
right now is iran that's where you need
these people to step up so we don't have
to you know what israel has done plenty
of stuff i mean israel will go take out
scientists israel is not afraid israel
is the kind of place that they'll
they'll play the proxy but they're not
afraid to play the direct without a
proxy i don't know if that makes sense
like they're not trying to use somebody
they're still relying on us to to take
charge they are but they'll still come
at you as one as well and say i did it
they'll do it alone yeah if we don't
like especially with this i wouldn't be
surprised if you see a legit
like you said this is us and we're not
not trying to hide it you know attack on
uh on different whether it's nuke sites
or or scientific scientist locations or
what have you so
it'll be interesting to see what happens
all i know is i'd love to see iran
open up so we can go toward and show the
entire place and see how beautiful of a
country iran is so you go to a lot of
museums there's a hundred year old
building 200 year old building you go to
like 3 000 year old building so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]